[Music]
we've all gotten used to recycling
bottles cans and paper products well
some of us have but did you ever wonder
what happens to old toothbrushes pens
coffee capsules and toys they're a lot
harder to recycle so they often end up
in landfills incinerators or even in the
ocean now an innovative new jersey-based
company is trying to tackle this problem
both here at home and overseas Roxana
Saberi has the story from above the
coast of southwest England shines
pristine that's where a whole load of
plastic usually washes in but buried in
the rocky crevices Emilie Stephenson
spots scraps of trash as soon as your
eyes adjust to see the plastics you see
everywhere the 21 year old has spent
nearly half her life cleaning up these
shores how does what you find today
compared to what you found 10 years ago
I think we're definitely finding more
plastic bottles and or more plastics in
general including bag after perfectly
preserved bag of chips this was the
first Walker's Chris packet that I found
and on the back there 16th of August
1997 so it's the same ages me made of
metallus eyes plastic bags of chips are
hard to recycle which is why they often
wash up on shore this is now the oldest
thing I've ever found I realized I need
to do something so she made this dress
there's 23 bags of crisps on there out
of bags of Walkers crisps the United
Kingdom's biggest potato chip brand
known to Americans as Lay's
after wearing her creation to her
college graduation last year she used
the attention to push people to protest
by mailing their empty bags of chips
back to walkers walkers promised more
environmentally-friendly packaging by
2025
but Emily said that would be too late I
just thought it was crazy that
TerraCycle was already able to recycle
Chris packets
why aren't they working together our
purpose is to eliminate the idea of
waste I want to change the way people
look at garbage TerraCycle is a New
Jersey based company taking on trash
around the world this is just a huge
amount of opportunity in waste its
founder Tom Zaki dropped out of
Princeton University because he believed
waste was a treasure untapped it's
relatively unavailable we do with it
TerraCycle collect stuff to recycle
debris like cigarette butts and yes bags
of chips for free people can also pay to
send in their used packaging the
warehouse is like this one candy
wrappers chip bags Ziploc bags
TerraCycle then sorts through the
material and turns it into plastic
pellets which manufacturers buy to make
products like watering cans and picnic
tables this lumber has been made out of
capri-sun pouches exactly these products
are the result of research headed by
Rick salt nur and Tara cycles lab we
take materials rippln part and we can
figure out how do you put them back
together and what we can use them for
what has been the environmental impact
of TerraCycle so far Tara Siegel has
recycled millions of pounds of waste
plastic and materials throughout its
lifetime but critics point out that's a
small portion of the more than 8 billion
metric tons of plastic produced globally
since the 1950s most of which has not
been recycled and they say TerraCycle is
giving businesses an excuse to keep
using single-use packaging are you
taking away some of the responsibility
of businesses companies who work with
TerraCycle are taking a voluntary step
to create a better outcome for their
waste than doing nothing at all and
really
what they should do is design their way
out of it are you going to motivate
those companies to do that absolutely in
fact a new model we just launched called
loop does exactly that loop offers a new
way to shop with big-name brands selling
items in reusable containers you pay a
deposit and they arrive at your door
when they're done dirty no cleaning
thing we pick it up clean it and then it
goes around together still reusable
packaging also carries an environmental
cost the environmental impact of a steel
container is much higher than a
single-use plastic one Cornell
University professor Glenn Dowell is an
expert on the environmental
responsibility of businesses we think
about the footprint of the
transportation of getting the containers
back and forth it's going to be quite a
few times that these containers have to
be reused before they're better in an
environmental sense and that's not the
only challenge you're just changing the
container what about the contents I mean
you still have these wipes that are
really hard to recycle so the battle
we're picking is around disposable
packaging and showing we can create a
major solution there you're not fighting
this battle no because we're gonna pick
one battle at a time and try to solve
that in a big epic way back in England
Emily thinks loop will catch on for the
same reason Walkers crisps began
recycling through TerraCycle last
December the companies know that these
next generation don't want this plastic
they have to listen because else they
won't have customers in the future for a
generation she says is demanding change
now to create a cleaner earth for the
future
for CBS this morning Saturday Roxana
Saberi Padstow England it's such an epic
problem and with so many components but
it's gonna take customers like Emily who
basically say you've got to change yeah
I think for businesses and that idea
that it's one thing at a time you cannot
fight everything but one change if
everybody made one change what would
that impact yeah so my change is to
drink out of cups that I can wash from
now on that's my that's that's my thing
use a refillable water bear it is so
slap my hand if you catch me with any
paper or plastic